dans la 10e circonscription des yvelines
vous le savez nous nous intéressons
principalement est ce qui se passe dans
le sud du département la 10e
circonscription la république en marche
remporte ce premier tour devant les
républicains
elle détaille avec vous ou nicolas
landry le duel annoncé aura donc lieu
dans la 10e
aurore bergé d'un côté face à joe
frédéric poisson effectivement wilfried
aurore bergé candidate de la république
en marche est arrivé largement en tête
du premier tour avec plus de 46% des
voix
elle sera opposé au candidat du parti
chrétien-démocrate investi par les
républicains jean frédéric poisson
placer en seconde position en totalisant
19 12% des suffrages et pour le député
sortant engagés dans cette
circonscription depuis deux législatures
ce score est vécue comme une déception
je vous propose de l'écouter
une terrible gifle c'est une forte
incompréhension pour moi une forme
d'humiliation aussi très clairement
parce que j'ai passé
des années au service de ce territoire
au service de ses habitants de ces
communes
le fait que ce travail ne soient pas
reconnus dans les urnes veut dire une
forme d'ingratitude de la population que
je ne comprends pas maintenant il reste
un second tour il y a beaucoup de
des lecteurs à se mobiliser pour ce pour
ce second tour je pense que les français
rééquilibreront l'assemblée nationale
comme ils l'ont fait dans les élections
législatives précédentes
et si on détaille un petit peu plus le
score de la république en marche et
d'aurore berger prenons par exemple les
deux plus grosses communes de la
circonscription avec rambouillet
maurepas où elle dépasse les 40%
elle atteint même 50 6% des voix dans la
commune de la queue-lez-yvelines une
satisfaction pour la candidate elle est
en ballottage favorable pour le week-end
prochain
on a fait une campagne pour pour le
président de la république et le projet
de réforme qu'on a envie de voir mises
en oeuvre pour le renouvellement
politique et le renouveau démocratique
et puis on a fait une campagne données
de terrain on n'a pas fait une campagne
de notables on est allé voir les gens
dans les écoles dans les gares chez eux
on a essayé de les mobiliser partout
tous les jours presque 24 heures sur 24
il faut qu'il vienne se mobiliser et
qu'il vienne le 18 juin prochain mais on
va continuer on va continuer à
collaborer les projets ensemble
on va continuer la concertation va
continuer les réunions et on va
continuer à aller vers eux plutôt que d
attendre qu ils viennent vers nous c'est
ça qu'on va changer de manière durable
dans ce département est partout en
france
première force de gauche dans la
circonscription la france insoumise
vagin nicoletta arrive en troisième
position
en totalisant plus de 8% à trois voix
près il prend même la seconde place
devant jean frédéric poisson dans la
commune de coignières comme vous pouvez
le voir à l'image
l'écologiste david jutier prend la
cinquième place et pour le second tour
il prend personnellement position pour
un vote ni droite ni droite le candidat
europe ecologie les verts devancent le
socialiste jean-claude husson
à gauche les consignes de vote sont
différentes en fonction des candidats je
vous propose d'écouter benjamin
nicoletta et jean claude husson sur ce
sujet je peux pas évidemment appelé à
voter ont remercié puisqu'on est dans
l'opposition et qu'on veut se battre
contre ça mais jean frédéric poisson ça
me pose un gros problème puisque c'est
quand même un mouvement qui est ancré à
droite
radical j'ai appelé à battre jean
frédéric poisson parce que j'ai
travaillé avec lui à l'agglomération et
qu' il ya beaucoup de choses à dire
contre sa manière de faire qui est
totalement inacceptable
autre formation politique qui a souffert
pendant ce scrutin ce premier tour c'est
le front national ça s'est confirmé
aussi sur cette 10e circonscription
effectivement wilfried le françois le
vot obtenu près de 8% des voix
il termine à la 4e place derrière la
france insoumise pour le second tour il
appelle à voter contre la candidate de
la république en marche pour je le cite
contrer le programme européen de
dérégulation économique et de réforme de
la structure familiale du côté de
philippe chevrier le candidat du front
libérer la consigne de vote semble la
même mais il appelle directement à voter
pour jean frédéric poisson alors au
total c'est près de 50 si ce sont près
par don de 56 % des électeurs de la 10e
circonscription qui se sont déplacés ce
dimanche 11 juin
une participation en baisse de cinq
points par rapport aux élections
législatives de 2012
merci nicolas dans drire